this just in there will be no sarcasm on
this year's You Tube boxing stream psi
logger poll will not be committed by
these two gentlemen the crowd are happy
about it Brian yeah I've seen some twits
yeah a couple of people but then a lot
of people also like genuinely genuinely
well done the cable a Joella thoroughly
delighted for these lads they are good
they're great lads yet people they're
being in there yeah they've box before
open box before no because they've live
their dream in the ring and you've
obviously not lived your dream of
commentating a livestream on Sky Sports
a new tube at the same time probably
across the Atlantic at the same time
really don't get your dreams that's fine
thank you don't be tweeting joined
gibble because they've done not they
wanted me to do it with them don't
angrily tweet them clear some reason sky
didn't want to go with me I mean if I
was friendly know why I'm on you on the
live stream
that's awkward they're family friendly
and I mean is it because you swore in
the live press conference Brian what
okay there are a few people suggesting
that although ksi also swore and yeah
they're promoting ksi log and Paul yeah
you know like they've they've done a few
things in their time yeah a couple of
offensive things that doesn't matter
bringing the cash it doesn't matter I'm
Rupert Murdoch shouts secure the bag to
be fair though their decisions fine
absolutely there are there are a few
opinions out there why I haven't been
chosen you know maybe they do invest a
lot of money every single weekend going
head to head with the kickoff for and
when I say head it's more like head to
Uncle yeah I'm sort of had to solve
because we are the biggest football live
stream on YouTube it's fair to say we're
not winning we're sort of we're lapping
them to it to its agreeable time we
don't even need to list the numbers here
like we're not the corporation it's a
bit like WWF versus WCW when WCW all
right at the end yeah you know me and
you had the money didn't have the nor
how one thousand concurrent live numbers
585 thousand Brian I've never done
before pretty much in football
generally let alone what we do on
we don't the actual [__] footage of
the football it's just literally people
watching it and going it was good but
the thing is happy I actually did get an
offer or someone reached out rather to
say if we potentially if I to be honest
could potentially not not you yeah do
something with DES or not now however
I'm not leaving my boy all right
I'm not leaving my boy okay and I'm not
leaving my audience because what I also
realize is half of the people I'm gonna
get the American half of them are gonna
get the English so whether I was on sky
or thought it wouldn't be to everyone
anyway and then how do we solve this
problem us we can be trans-atlantic
brands so basically get live stream on
the true Jordi YouTube channel during
the fight
where everyone can watch it right say
what I want like and drink what I want I
can do what a [__] what exactly you
la can do it for free wither for free
come and do it for free and if you don't
like it you're transatlantic phobic can
we also to say can we also to say you
can still buy if Skylanders on are
worried we're gonna you still like the
pay-per-view yeah you just have a song
yeah you with it on the phone it's
alright sky its writes his own you still
got your money you're gonna lose out
alright people are just gonna mute you
you don't get less money because people
mute you alright that's fine you can
join us so do that join us during the
case I longer qualify put us on a Wii I
mean I'm gonna be really drunk but you
know the great thing about it it's 4:00
in the morning so we're gonna be late
we're on the live stream we have to go
wow what a moment this is amazing guys
welcome back just a few messages here
from our sponsor this we can just go
what do you really think Brian just puts
them in the [__] headlock exactly
yeah and that's the kind of fantastic
read you can get more of that analysis
yeah I do wonder why Skye didn't choose
me you get more of that analysis right
yeah good on the true Jordi YouTube
delight that subscribe notifications on
dude the North it cuz you might you know
what I mean it's gonna be late at night
North acacia notification game cheers
guys good now I'm with the news
[Music]
some of you may have seen him I did a
tweet recently about an idea I had for
Christmas you know that time of the year
when everyone spends loads of money the
most wonderful time of the year I put up
just an idea all the UK YouTube I should
get together record a Christmas song for
charity to go for Christmas number one
we've had some good responses and one
youtuber god bless him if I'm sort of
son are in this yeah he would be my ELF
feel bigger come :
it straightaway Malfoy he's got the
scales A's so I could help you with this
he's gonna go and approach all of the
youtubers and try and corral them as
sort of buddy the elf
in this scenario and he is a bit like
that he's excitable he's definitely
excited I mean ever there was a you try
makeup and saw you got to tweet your
favorite youtubers tell them and I'm
specifically saying the ones over a
million we don't want any freeloaders on
yes
if this Christmas single doesn't happen
you know your favourite youtubers just
don't give a [__] about charity or worse
Christmas songs I mean who doesn't like
Christmas songs like I'm gonna sign hate
and charity your Christmas songs do
these youtubers know it's Christmas time
at or do they have any subscribers or
strugglin well that would be nice for
anyone who's 700k oh yeah you look at
your pluck nightmare we've all got a
plaque who hasn't got one if you can't
get 100k subs I'd say you're you're
worse than irrelevant there's homeless
guys who have given bigger performances
than you have homeless guys definitely
more influential yeah I'll have some of
those I look at them I think
oh so you're for did that not only that
but I always walk around the streets now
they definitely influenced me to cross
the road absolutely justified as well of
that that's a terrible joke we will
actually be helping homeless people this
Christmas and if you don't try and help
myself those homeless people oh then get
[__] I did ring one youtuber Big Daddy
Zuka from the side man I'm in Dubai me
I'm a bit busy right now I'll get back
that'll be right I'm helping these poor
people in Dubai shut down the phone just
gonna sell enough to actually help
people we need the sidemen so I'm just
calling calling out the sidemen right
now get on it do it you know I mean will
even let JJ rock someone sparred with
ksi I did an interview afterwards all
right we're here inside city boxing with
Muslim case
first sparring partner here in Las Vegas
for ksi if he's the first one imagine
what the last one looks like Matt and
they go we'll start you off easy and you
walk in the ring and go but for some
reason and I'm not stereotyping yeah but
he just I just believe him like as in he
looks the part doesn't he yeah got a
sweat on looks like he lives and
breathes the gym doesn't [__] doesn't he
look a bit like the guy who is in creed
that's what I think that's what it is
yeah very well chaos a can punch we've
got a confirmed guy firm he can punch
this just in case I can pawn trillion
he's going to win the fight thank God
yeah what I like about this gym is
they've got inspirational quotes
duct-taped to the wall the harder you
work the luckier you are well I must not
be working very hard then tell me about
it I thought I was gonna take it easy I
was just gonna play around full of it
but we started throwing those punches
like like a pro that's when I had to
turn it up on them and he kept his
composure he started dogging it out with
me you can say judge in disrespect I
want to see a good fight whoever wins
may the best man win because without
head cards it's a different game this
time as he just said he was dogging out
with us he was willing to go into the
trenches I'm gonna see a real fight when
I'm just gonna see two boys in a ring
Conor McGregor says he's buck by the
time this video comes out he'll have
said he's gone again not I mean yeah you
saw such a flick
yes tour of the notorious Conor McGregor
will take place on January 18th in the
t-mobile Arena in Las Vegas Nevada I'm a
prime physical condition I have agreed
the date with you
a stumble day you're going to say
opponent ask the USP opponent is because
I do not give a [__] I feel like there
isn't an agreement here and I feel like
he's trying to put pressure on the UFC
yeah to force the fight up and maybe
he's in contract disputes with them
they're quarreling over money and if he
comes out and says it's January and he
feels the public will put pressure on
the EOC to force them to agree to the
terms that he's setting but the UFC
won't do [__] they've got ESPN money
coming in now so they're not relying on
pay-per-view money from Conor McGregor
so Conor McGregor's star power is still
important to the UFC but because he's
only fought once in the UFC in the last
three years is probably at one of the
weakest points his career has ever been
in terms of being able to bully then if
Connor loses his next fight that would
be a massive
Laufey the memories that we have of
Conor McGregor to wait will champion
holding their belts above the kids the
last time we seen a win him win a fight
was 2016 they're fading and now he's
becoming more known for his whiskey it
it's a little bit like David Beckham
David Beckham was a world-class
footballer most people just forgotten
all of that because he's now known for
his fashion and his other [__] that
he does people forget that he's a
world-class footballer and for me Conor
McGregor's reputation as a world-class
fighter is is fading because he doesn't
stay inactive now he's claiming he wants
to fight three times next year and he's
naming killers that he wants to fight I
respect that right he's coming out with
people like Maz Vidal Nate Diaz oh I
just don't believe it anymore because he
said so many times I'm back you know I'm
ready to fight the things he said on the
run up to the khabib fight I don't
believe it anymore is it the boy who
cried wolf or them a little bit it's I
just show me don't [__] talk anymore
as great as he is at talking that's all
he's become now I want to see him
display the great skills that got him
the suit the whiskey the whole [__]
lock you sound like a disappointed
girlfriend a little bit like when they
go when he goes I'll be home for a
dinner love and you go I'll believe it
when I see it Connor when I've got your
[__] cabbage and potatoes on the
table and you haven't come through the
door three nights in a row her love
that's [__] not on so from one rich
man who's completely out of touch with
reality - got a chain and gold brings on
all you might right the difference is is
I know how ridiculous I am yes yeah only
white looks in the mirror and actually
goes looking good Olli Olli wait for
those who don't know is sort of in the
friendship group of Casper your sog all
of those guys all the great look not to
be Fae they're all nice guys as much as
I've said like little digs and taking
the piss and that as I do
so they date out of ten guys no but
they're actually Sounders four but Olli
has taken a lot of stick over the years
for his merch juicy and Jack mate did
videos about it they're in a group of
family-friendly content creators and
people like me and Jack mate and you and
that we make content that's not for the
same age group so when we're the same
age roughly and we look at what they're
making it's easy for us to go how that
[__] but it's not meant for us right so
I cut him some slack and I and I tried
to sort of realize that over the years
of you can't just [__] on people's
content when it's not
for you however oh this was so bad
I've watched a little bit of it I know
that was enough for me ago true news
well he isn't a bad-looking guy by any
means
he's an already looking guy I mean he
looks pretty good there doesn't mean
it's like Jimmy Neutron had a glower so
this is him and his girlfriend I've just
got to say and I'm sure he has it a lot
this punching and then there's oli white
punching only you should box not
seriously I'd be relieved you know what
I'm sorry I'll be Ruiz of dating heesu
shouldn't be as good as he is yeah the
women but yeah especially not it that
way hard I'm joking I'm joking come on
relax it's roasting a middle-class white
guy what's your [__] problem the eyes
this guy's at everything [__] handed
to him by YouTube and we're just having
a little joke McDonald's offered him a
brand deal where the whole thing is down
you did once get offered a job at
McDonald's though that's technically a
brand of sorts
yeah you've got the other McDonald's
offered him a brand deal and definitely
chloroformed over there the execution it
wasn't great now I've heard that you can
apply for a job at McDonald's using
Alexa if you're gonna do a brand deal
just be honest about it
don't put this [__] like oh let's do
this today naughty not funny about it in
the very top line of the video it's got
this video sponsored by McDonald's so
when he goes I've heard he's literally
heard from the brand team at McDonald's
that you can do this his agent heard and
his agent was i after my tablet said
this is what you've got to do this is
not how the meeting goes all right Ally
you can actually get a job on Alexa from
McDonald's no way I must get a job but
there's nothing wrong with making money
on YouTube there's nothing wrong with
wanting to do that but just be honest if
I just say look McDonald's want me to do
a day's work in there I'm gonna find out
more about what it's like I'm gonna talk
to people maybe this is preconception
that people at McDonald's they don't
like the job because it is footmen
minimum wage it is difficult but maybe
if I talk to them I might learn
something because I'm a youtuber who's
never done a day's work in his [__]
life
so therefore make it a bit of actual
scope about what it's like to live a
normal life oh just the execution of
this this is like the sequel to alfea's
one pound
basically so I thought why not try and
apply and get a job at McDonald's
because you're a multi-millionaire
you're taking jobs off the working
classes there's already a shortage in
Britain you're a millionaire why are you
trying to get a job at McDonald's prick
what's wrong with his wrists he's fresh
out in the hospital he doesn't want to
tell people that's actually a hospital
town yeah he released from the metal
hominy yeah who's so ill he thought
McDonald's was the greatest place on
earth
obviously this is a brand deal with
Alexa all over and he's wearing a not
will watch so they had blue I assume
that's why hey Siri
get me a [__] job I don't want fair
play to you Siri fair play that's the
response you're actually what when you
apply for a job at McDonald's Siri goes
calling the nearest mental health I
can't do this to you Brian I'm sorry
Brian you've been through quite enough
of the lasting attitude got that and my
application he goes I didn't get the job
but it turns out Alexa does work I'm
just really shitty jobs yeah fill the
application yes you said I was too much
of a [__]
today I love the fact that this guy has
never had a job in real life and you
actually think that the likelihood of
people believing that is just oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah well you could start
seeing do sure when do I start half an
hour you can you can you get in yeah
yeah no I'm on my way I love about it is
agents going I'm still gonna take 10% of
those wages now having a job at
McDonald's will help me build skills
that will stay with you for life to be
fair that's actually true but not not
all right
I never it will help you build a
resentment to never want to work with
customers ever again to get a better job
and that will stay with you for life
speaking from experience I worked in a
butcher shop I cleaned blood off the
walls of fries as they and II worked in
a butcher shop dried my [__] knuckles
out right I worked in a cruel shop we
within Taub line up like [__]
fatso I need a large over here I
empathize with everyone who works in
these because I've done it
I don't patronize people as if they're
[__] changing the world yeah what
they do they know how hard it is to do
that job so the key thing to remember
here specifically from McDonald's he
will have been paid for this one video
or more than every single person in this
video at McDonald's makes in a year
facts I know this [__] cuz I work in
YouTube I'm telling you the [__]
truth he's loaded I've got some good
brand deals of my time using yes I've
never worn a handle that's not true that
one that was by choice yeah well I gave
my own time once again is my choice
however more in this video made by him
than they make in a year per expression
is exactly how I felt working customer
services just dead inside so imagine
you're already working customer services
and then Olly white turned up at your
work I think at that point I would have
quit
see all right he said he's not winning
an Oscar oh my god they're literally
making me warmer I'd love to see his
face when his girlfriend takes her
clothes off because I mean I bet he's
really impressed I think all he looks
terrified that he's gonna be hit with
some sort of working class information
oh my god what is he going this yeah
some days I get on D boss sorry though
what Ali's mumbled amazing there because
what he's just realized this he's
replying amazing to a man going I learn
to turn this machine on and press his
bit down and he's gone to work they are
not machine dream to make magic up even
the machines
literally in the middle of the
restaurant this guy's in front of him
and he just went whoa
just Libra clearing it all over the
place whoa spotted something let's see
how people in this place really feel
this guy is literally looking around
like [__] didn't lose a leg on
Vietnam for this [__] only imagine when
thinking about what the back end of
McDonald's was like did he imagine that
pixies just [__] burgers Oh what is
it that he thought McDonald's did in the
back you don't remember this is a guy
who's made a living off of hitting the
upload button you know like to him this
is military tournament in this is like a
conglomerate like wow Phil Gates [__]
yeah dude I mean you guys actually
reinvested the money that people gave
you this is memory here do any of you
also go home and sit in bath Sabine see
she doesn't want to [__] all those
eyes you've got to be honest yeah she
has not in hit the mood for his [__]
right you know when someone asks you
that you're in the job you're like I'm
here already I've come in this morning
I'm doing my job
don't ask me this [__] skill well
clearly Frey and [__] chips me you
stood next was watching his fried
chicken yeah to look happy whilst I
actually don't feel happy that's
actually a massive skill unfortunately
I'm still working on closing my eyes and
thinking about someone until they
spontaneously combust yeah maybe that
will come in the next five seconds
because you're working McDonald's will
you please make me some food
[Laughter]
he was working in a place where they
make food and he said can you make me
some food I actually have met him once
before seems like a nice guy but no
problem with I want to make loads of
money got no problem one do brand deals
with McDonald's it's just a Patran izing
tone of this whole thing that comes
across as a completely out of touch a
person with reality of regular people in
it it everything that people have been
saying over the years like them being
like middle-class guys and bit ignorant
he's just vindicated a lead you know it
pisses people off people think they feel
good at what you do then you'll make a
lot of money what you've done here is
you've made a lot of money and you've
done it badly you've made a lot of money
and you could have made a good video you
made a bad video for a lot of money I
just didn't kids attitude towards people
this is bit it's off it it's part
realizing acting like working at
McDonald's is like the greatest thing
ever people have those jobs and actually
it is a difficult time and like making
ends meet at the end of the month like
real issues that people who work they
have to go through or ignored
consistently throughout this because
he's having fun making a McFlurry like
I'm not saying the guys done the worst
thing in the world and obviously we make
what jobs in that context he hasn't
killed anyone yeah he hasn't anything
really bad a [__] video with a [__] torn
and completely misjudged and showing
himself up for being a bit of a [__] I
don't think he's a nasty human being
I just think being a youtuber you lose
grip on reality and sometimes it rears
its ugly head in certain videos where
you see some youtubers just completely
get it wrong and just sure that they
[__] not thinking mmm and make a year
of true news it's unbelievable really
yeah I'm just grateful for all those
youtubers we're coming up to one year
anniversary of true news thank you yeah
for the content that's up in the
comments I do our works of McDonald's
and she gets bullied by managers and
abused by customers every shift such a
[__] of a place to work good brand
Dilma Thanks I worked at McDonald's
nearly a year ago and I can assure you
it is hands-down the worst job I've ever
worked the managers were appalling the
training was practically non-existent
the way we were trapped was borderline
abusive they took advantage of the fact
that the majority of staff who were
young teens did not know their employee
rights but I as a law student knew my
rights and confronted them about it when
I confronted them they played dumb
unless
were genuinely just stupid which would
not surprise me Meena and claim that
McDonald's policy [__] them
however the policy that they claimed or
backed them up was contradictory to
government policy this is getting
interesting so the next day I read more
printed out the relevant policies
brought them in and quit followed by an
extensive complaint in the HR and boss
21 considering working the McDonald's
who only do it as an absolute last
resort I guess that's a brand deal that
McDonald's went looking for but have
brought on themselves by who they chose
to execute this just a little word of
advice when you think you're playing
safe sometimes you're not you know what
I mean just because someone doesn't
sweat doesn't mean they won't completely
[__] up a video in their own unique way
just the Brunn's who would avoid a
person like me yeah maybe maybe there's
a reason to have someone who swears in
videos sometimes maybe you get more
authenticity someone who actually has
worked for a living for many years
having said that we will be having it
almost later this afternoon
so no angry when I saw why not let's
just hope it isn't being served up by
that cooked let's go to have five on
eight logging what I was interested in
how they respond to their newfound fame
they've got 1,000 subs now 6800 views on
their last video I feel like now in the
new episode they're gonna put on a bit
more of a show they're gonna be like my
people are watching us now let's jazz it
up absolutely let's say well there goes
it here we go before we get going I do
want to shout out to true G already he's
blown up my youtube channel and though
he didn't have a lot of positive things
to say ah mean mean big bad Brian and
say nice things I thought it I do
appreciate being featured on his youtube
channel and I hope that you know he
brings me back and to talk on one of his
podcast podcast now when we watch the
joke
there's a moment where he starts
thinking that he's gonna be featured on
the live show and he's like you want me
to come up on stage with you
that's what it's like being me a little
bit like everyone I know they don't rub
it in here I'm Daniel just to be clear
when you've got a podcast and you know
this it's so weird how many people think
I got a good interview for you
you love to interview me who
who's up who's up what you well you know
someone Oh me I've had mental illness
yeah I've had depression yeah I don't
think you understand the the point of
the podcast it's not just sitting there
going have you had a hard life yeah that
is actually a lot of your questioning
almost submitted it yeah well I'm just
getting annoyed with how many people
think I'm fascinating yeah I'm not a
counselor who just happens to record
this session you should be though what
it does say though is that people see
you as someone they want to come and
chat to they feel like they when we're
doing the podcast they see themselves
sitting alongside us and they're going I
feel like we're gonna end up doing like
the call-in show like
Frasier Crane yeah remember for the head
your honor maybe I hear the Blues a
calling oh yeah farming simulator 19 is
a way that I can wind down and though
I'm not 14 I'm 24 I do work full-time
and like I said this is a kind of a way
to wind down for me I actually genuinely
think we've upset him and I want to
apologize yes because we know each other
so well we think it's okay because we
hammer each other like that they could
talk it'd just destroy everyone else but
it's obviously if we weren't meaning to
sort of yeah yeah yeah if anything it's
because we like you but I actually
really enjoyed how into the game that
they got and that was part of the fun
because even though it is a monotonous
game and it is a site you know you're
building a form that no one's ever gonna
give a [__] about oh that's the fun bit
because it's just your thing like on
battlefield no one cares about what I'm
doing and generally I'm not that great
anyway but I love it what don't and the
fact that I'm in the way yeah you often
sit and just laugh at me getting [__]
Murphy yeah again shout out at you
Trudy already he's insulting me now he's
actually pretending to have forgotten
your name as if you didn't even mean and
as I got [__] yeah you sure Jordy
garage in here he actually has er kind
of like my shop it's the casual where he
says his car is in the garage like my
[__] up arrogant because this is all
simulation there's no car needed fixed
part of me wonders if he brought it
himself just to have the need to have a
fix drop it else to have something to do
is I yeah I've got to take the car in
the garage that was running just fine
you're actually driving it right now is
that yeah just need to spec saying
it you don't you don't see that there's
a problem there's a picture light now
the lights out on it told you yeah yeah
show you around a little bit
this is so peaceful it's amazing
I wouldn't gone for that blue on the
tiles but fair plate no I definitely
would not but I let the music I don't go
upstairs to the best part thinking you
also just said I'm going upstairs to the
best part what do you think it's gonna
be double bed king-size Holly white
sitting there 100 just walking in the
money yeah 20 pound or there's actually
fully working McDonald's up here what is
this
Ross grocery most alone I don't know
this guy's a 24 year old man Oh Lords
where do we have our business beings
just right here we've got a real
business with real meetings here and
this guy is having a fictional I
genuinely feel like we could get this
guy to work for us he saw efficient it's
amazing he's [__] farming simulator
this man is Inception this he's
literally gone in and gone the guy in
the game will also play farming
simulator and on that there's actually a
guy in this farming simulator who's
playing farming simulator and he's going
around going trolling who is this
reality this is someone inside this
forming simulators go he's got he goes
to his regular job he sorts having
thoughts like did I think that was that
someone else sick or is someone clicking
a mouse to control me imagine if your
whole life is just that you're playing
true geordie simulator you know this
someone who's operating you going make
it wank again you're going what if this
is all a simulation what if everyone
watching us is really being simulated
into watching us into watching him in a
simulation who's actually playing
someone else in the simulation that
might actually be big there's so many
people out there going oh this makes
perfect sense now I mean I've been
operated by fourteen-year-old boy yeah
so that's his house like I said it's an
absolute mansion compared to mine mine
just a log cabin you know and they have
their business meeting is the other guy
the CEO and he is he so like the
groundsman yeah he
works in the business he's paid himself
a fictionally low way I love the fact
that he starts the game I'm gonna take
oh god I've got to go and work for that
boss again he gets home from work he's
like oh god it's been a hard day's work
well I've got a good stop my I've got a
clock in on my other job now me milk the
cut someone else might break in what in
this regional world and no one else is
playing just them - I love the fact that
he comes home to find he's been robbed
and he's like who done it who could have
done it and he goes knows his business
meeting with his man he's like yeah I
got robbed the other day this made so no
idea like you know that call you said
you like yeah yeah that and then and
then one day is driving along the
problem is their business is booming and
if they've come so far yeah if this is
episode 3 what episode they haven't
given them some room to grow they're
almost like they're showing too much
right now I want to see the struggle
this guy's simulator Pablo Escobar yeah
I mean yeah I'm too far women like on
grand theft auto or you start from
scratch you build it from the they've
they've come too far to be continuing
the dream episode 3 well where we going
with it yeah what dream we were smashed
it I've actually found another farm
simulator channel which is absolutely
raking the views we're gonna yeah look
at this this guy is five hundred and
thirty K subscribers man so all that
you've enjoyed this don't forget to hit
the like button subscribe to the true
Giada YouTube channel for more hits one
here is there's nothing but sheep and we
will see you on the next one